all right so google has had a habit of
every year picking a top of the line
manufacturer in the smartphone industry
to work with them to help produce the
once per year flagship nexus model for
the latest version of android and this
month slash next month is the time frame
for the next nexus to be released so
we've been sort of compiling the rumors
about who will be making the next one
would it be samsung would it be htc
again perhaps asus or motorola or
lg well yeah a ton of details are
emerging that are suggesting that the
next nexus will be made by lg in the
form of a pure vanilla android version
of the lg optimus g so a little bit
about the optimus g it's a pretty good
looking phone i'm not gonna lie
it has some nice hardware on the outside
it's a relatively clean looking device
some pretty relatively square edges it
has capacitive home back and
multitasking buttons on the front but of
course those would disappear in favor of
a larger screen and if it's a nexus it
should have those on-screen buttons like
the previous nexus did people don't
really notice this but lg has actually
consistently put really good hardware in
the devices it's just kind of held back
by their so-so software people like
touchwiz and people like sense ui and
motorola's skin but lg's skin has been
clunky and a little bit unintuitive for
a while not exactly the greatest skin
out there so that's held back their
devices so combining that excellent lg
hardware at least internally with some
amazing stock android which is naturally
great software that should produce a
pretty sweet nexus inside the new lg
nexus is rumored to have the beast the
qualcomm snapdragon s4 pro which is
pretty much hands down the best mobile
chip out there right now and it also
packs 2 gigabytes of ram a 4.7 inch 1280
by 768 ips display which should be
pretty bright in sunlight an 8 megapixel
camera and possibly maxing out at 16 or
32 gigs of internal storage sealed
battery so no external sd card support
also nfc support is included and
wireless charging out the box is on the
spec list this is on a lot of rumored
spec lists so this is sort of a back of
the head thing for me but it's possible
and on top of all this great hardware
the lg nexus would be running android
4.2 which is on the rumored spec list
now android 4.1 is jelly bean so 4.2 is
key lime pie maybe and what would they
call it would be the uh it's not the
galaxy nexus 2 because galaxy is a
samsung thing but lg optimus g nexus
sounds a little too much maybe lg
optimus nexus or just just optimus nexus
that's it there it is right there boom
patented so curling all these ideas
together and with a little bit of
photoshop ability bam that's what it
could look like
not bad huh
not bad at all either way the rumors are
pegging a late october announcement and
a mid-november actual launch so we won't
have to wait that long to see all the
stuff in action anyway i'm excited to
see the first snapdragon s4 pro phones
in the first place give a thumbs up on
this video if you're excited to see just
whatever google has up their sleeves to
release next this doesn't count out any
of the rumors of multiple nexus devices
we already have i've done a video on my
wish list for the next nexus so if you
want to check out that video bam there
it is and that should be just clickable
if you're on youtube
desktop that's an annotation it's
not on mobile yet i should rant about
that either way i'm excited for the next
nexus and the future of android and i
hope you guys are too
thanks for watching this video and i
will talk to you guys in the next one
you